How many children have you killed,
Pierce? Israel is not killing children.
Israel is not killing children. Hamas is
using them is killing children every
single day. This is a bad label you're
putting on Israel. No, it's not true.
Why? No, it's not actually. And what
you're trying to do is be very measly
with your words. No. The truth is The
truth is you are killing a lot of
children. You would argue you're
hanging shields and you know, let me
finish my question to you. You are
killing a lot of children on a daily
basis.
When I give10 in charity and it is
consumed, the rewards come to an end.
However, if I give to a wak, then you've
put your money into something permanent,
which means a endowment that continues
to give on your behalf until the day you
meet Allah subhana wa tala. Subhan
Allah. That is amazing. Here at Im
Legacy, brothers and sisters, we want
you to build a legacy with your saddaka.
Where will your donation be going?
events, global events inspiring the iman
of millions around the world. Education,
free Quran lessons, free lectures, free
reminders. Number three, media content
for kids, educational shows, spiritual
Islamic shows online, brothers and
sisters. Go to the link inshallah and
donate in this blessed 10 days
inshallah. May Allah bless you guys.
Asalam
alalayikum. Asalam guys. So this is
another video of our pro Palestinian
activist Pierers Morgan. Brothers and
sisters, subhan Allah. He has changed
his tune drastically and he is now
interviewing and questioning
cross-examining the ambassador to
Israel, this genocidal maniac woman.
Let's go in say let's start this
inshallah with the former prime minister
of Israel telling us what he thinks that
he's nothing no different to them
anyways. But let's see what he has to
say about what the Israelis, the
genocidal maniacs are doing to the
Palestinians. Israeli Prime Minister
Ahood Omare has denied that Israel would
kill civilians deliberately and deny the
charge of war crimes. He now says this.
The statements made by Israeli cabinet
ministers, the leading cabinet ministers
that say we should starve Gaza, what is
it if not a war crime? I mean, how can a
serious person
uh representing the Israeli government
uh can spell it out in such an explicit
manner that we should starve Gaza, that
there should be no supply of basic uh
fundamental uh humanitarian needs to a
couple of millions people living there.
They are uh uh terrorists that uh we
need to fight. But this is not a war
against Hamas. This looks more and more
like a political war of the Israeli
prime minister and the cabinet and the
group of thugs which are now
representing the Israeli government
inside Israel and across the world are
committing uh actions which can't be
interpreted in any other way. Well,
exactly. They are genocidal thugs, not
just ths themselves. So, let's get
straight into Piers Morgan. Let's see
what he had to say to the ambassador of
Israel to the UK. Israeli ambassador to
the UK, Zippy Hot. Um, ambassador,
welcome back to Uncensored. Good
evening, Pierce.
Incredibly damning uh comments from two
former prime ministers of Israel and a
former deputy chief of staff of the
Israeli army. When you hear what they
have to say, uh, surely it gives you
pause for thought, doesn't it? Well,
it's quite obvious for someone like you
that understands politics that those
people are coming from the opposition.
Uh they their job in their opinion is to
fight whatever the government is doing.
I think it's very
antipatriotic not to support Israel's
war when we are fighting the most
justified war in the world against a
terror group that committed the worst
atrocities at the 7th of October. Just
today we remember 600 days. It is
antiatriotic to be speaking out against
genocide. There you go, guys. It is
antipatriotic. We just covered it. Let's
carry on. We still have 58 hostages in
captivity. And I'm afraid to say uh
nowadays in Israel, you can't find even
one leader that will say he's willing to
live with Hamas on its doorstep. Let's
just stop there for a second. She said
they have 58 hostages. No, they don't.
They are prisoners of war. Why? Because
those 58 hostages, all of them, by the
way, guys, are IDF soldiers. The
civilians that were amongst the
hostages, prisoners, they were released.
Right now, 58 of those hostages, they're
not hostages, prisoners are IDF
soldiers, combatants. Yes. According to
that, just want to make that definition
clear that they are not innocent
civilians. They are IDF soldiers. If
those people have any criticism, they
should offer a plan how Hamas will be
removed from the Gaza Strip from
controlling the doorstep of Israel, not
committing the 7th of October. Again, I
I didn't get to hear that, not from
European leaders that are criticizing
Israel uh and not from those opposition
former leaders. So, I I I must say that
in the end of the day, Israel has a
serious threat on its security. You will
agree with that. Uh, no one wants to see
people being massacred in their homes
like we've seen at the 7th of October.
And in order to do that, the aims of the
war are still relevant. We want to bring
back our hostages and we want to make
sure kamas want control of the Gaza
Strip. Every leader in the world in the
western world agrees on those two aims.
Well, fantastic. Okay, firstly, number
one, like I said before, we'll repeat
that as well. They are not hostages.
They are IDF soldiers. 50 of them are
full IDF soldiers. Number 16, in fact,
they are. And number two, and they're
talking about that, you know, how to
protect the Israelis, etc. The biggest
anti-semmites, anti-semitics are you
guys. You guys are the biggest Zionists
are the biggest anti-semites. I'm
telling you guys, if you want them to go
from your doorstep, if I go and occupy a
specific house, I have to expect the
occupants of those house to fight me.
And if I can subdue them oneh hour and
put them in the corner of a house, I
have to expect that. And that's when
under UN law that they have a right to
arm resistance. Okay. So, what we're
talking about is armed resistance of a
group. Poor Hamas to aside, armed
resistance is allowed. So I have to
expect that rather the option the root
of the problem is what I do not occupy
the house I have no right to the stolen
uh house I don't steal the land and I
just go and leave I go that is the
solution so then both everyone is safe
and the Jews the Muslims and the
Christians can live on those lands like
they did for centuries under Muslim rule
and can go back to that you know you and
I have spoken regularly uh or on a
number of occasions throughout this war
I've always said from the start as you
know that Israel had an absol absolute
right and indeed duty to its people to
defend itself after those appalling
attacks and my position about that
hasn't changed but I also kept asking
one question which was what is a
proportionate response and I've got to
tell you that in the last few weeks I
have found the Israeli government
strategy in Gaza to be utterly
disproportionate and I'll explain to you
why when you launch a blockade for
nearly three months to a population
which already has seen much of their
possessions, their land, their
buildings, their homes decimated by
bombardment after bombardment. When you
say that you're going to launch a
blockade on aid and food to a population
where 50% are under 18, you are
pursuing, it seems to me, as
audacy of starvation towards obviously
because of the nature of the population
in Gaza of a lot of children and that is
a war crime. I mean yes he talks about
what's the proportional response you
know you heard him say you know what's a
proportionate response what's a
proportional response Pierers Morgan
your proportionate response your
proportion of Russia compared to Israel
is like this Russia does this it's a
genocide Israel had to do that for you
to be like ah now it's not do you see
the two-tier morality they have that's
what it is so your proportional response
now it's re reached a threshold for but
for Russia it was here let's carry on I
mean what else do you call it Um, I
think when you look at at the facts and
and you should look at the facts,
letting in 25,000 trucks with tons of
aid, this is not a policy of starvation.
Now, let me tell you what was Israel's
policy from the beginning of the war.
From the beginning of the war, we
created a very clear distinction between
the terrorists. We're talking about
50,000 people that embedded themselves
in population. As you know, just now you
just mentioned Muhammad Senoir. He was
found under a hospital, under the
European hospital. was hiding there
because he knows exactly how the world
reacts when Israel attacks hospitals.
But those hospitals being abused and
being used as a terror facilities. This
is why Israel is allowed to to operate
there. Now, I'm going back to the policy
of aid. Uh in the last few days, as you
know, Israel is launching a new program,
a new mechanism to deliver aid because
unfortunately, and I'm saying that with
a big pain, Hamas was looting the aid
that all all the world wanted to.
Interesting. So, for example, um we let
in 25,000 lorries, whatever it is, as
long as commit genocide, it's fine. As
long as we let some, you know, you know,
we I've killed your family members, but
you know, I gave you some chocolate bars
and I gave you some food, etc. What the
hell are you talking about? And they
talk about Hamas looting the one thing I
want to know is if Hamas is smuggling
weapons, like weapons or whatever it is,
arms, etc. How can they not smuggle
food? If they can smuggle weapons, I'm
sure, so I'm just thinking, how does
Hamas rely on the looting of the food
that's come from? It doesn't make sense.
They are smuggling weapons. weapons. Do
you think they cannot smuggle some food
and here and rice and this that? Do you
think they cannot do that? Come on. Use
use your brain, guys. Yeah. Okay, that
does not make sense to me. Been let into
Gaza now. Everyone is interested that
the population won't be starving. We
don't want to see pictures of children.
They don't have something to eat. We all
share the same interest. But at the same
time, if Hamas is looting the aid, then
we are empowering the war machine. And
according to the international law, no
country in the world has obligation to
feed the war machine of the enemy. And
this what happened in the last few
months. This is why Israel had to change
the mechanism. This is why American
companies are involved. So we'll have a
buffer. We we won't have to see Israeli
soldiers uh combating Hamas while
they're trying to loot the aid. The
whole procedure is much more effective.
And just in the last few days, we saw
kamas putting uh putting barriers for
the population not to get not to receive
this aid. This is the same kamas that
use his own people as human shields. So
we are talking about situation uh
talking about Hamas using its uh um
population as human shields. Okay, let's
do let's do some reading. So sisters,
let's just check this. So this is from
Harrett. So in Israeli media, yeah, easy
and effective Israeli use of human
shields in Gaza was systematic soldiers
was systematic soldiers and former
detainees tell AP. Okay. The several
Palestinians and IDF soldiers told the
Associated Press that Israeli troops are
systematically forcing Palestinians to
act as human shields in Gaza, sending
them to into buildings and tunnels and
check for explosive militants. Brothers
and sisters, every accusation is a
confession. Just wanted to highlight
that it's very difficult, very
complicated. Once Israel is fighting the
Hamas terrorists, we still want aid to
get in. And the mechanism I believe that
Israel is putting now forward is so much
better than the one that in the end of
the day is empowering Hamas. The problem
is that whilst you're saying all this
and trying to justify it, you've got
people like Smodrich coming out and
making it absolutely crystal clear what
the real plan is, which is to completely
clean out Gaza all the Palestinians and
get them into quotes the third country.
That is a form of genocide. Is it the
deliberate targeting of people based on
ethnicity and displacing them from their
homes and killing a lot of them in the
process? I don't know what else you
would call it. I've resisted using the
word genocide about this. But when I
watch what Oh, yeah. Me, no, you
definitely resisted using uh the word
genocide. No doubt about that, my
friend. Proh, we're not going to forget.
But PS, don't don't think that me
reacting this and showing, you know, I'm
just showing this so the whole world can
see. Even someone like you who was so
determined not to use the word genocide
and threshold was so large and it cost
thousands of 50 plus thousand god knows
that we know of innocent people dying.
I'm just trying to show the world that
even someone like you Yes. who was a
vile individual. Even someone like you
is now speaking up. I'm just trying to
show that that reality. Not that I'm
using this as a a point for you. You
have zero points. You're a minus my
friend. Rich was saying and studied the
exact words that he said. it is very
hard to reach any other conclusion than
that he is waging a strategy of genocide
and would like to cleanse as he put it
the whole Gaza strip of all the
Palestinians. So you can try and dress
up that blockade which is what it was
for 3 months where we saw the starving
children you say you're concerned about.
But you've got Smodri there actually
laying bare the real plan which is to
get all the Palestinians out of Gaza.
And that is a form of genocide, isn't
it? What else do you call it? Have a
strong military but but very vulnerable
population that been hit by a terror
organization. We're a small country.
We're a small country that it borders
being invaded. Fine. I just asked you a
question as to whether you have the
strongest military in the Middle East.
You accept you do. We do. But at the
same time, we're a very vulnerable
country when we are surrounded by
radical Islamist in including backed up
by here to defend radical. I don't
understand. Very vulnerable country. I
don't understand. You've got bunkers.
You've got all these systems, alarms,
sirens, all this kind of stuff, defense
systems, etc. What do you mean by
vulnerable? If there's anyone that's
vulnerable, it's the Palestinians. They
have none of them. That's the reason why
the death toll has been so humongous
proportionately on the side of the
Palestinians. So, I don't understand
what you mean by your vulnerable. And
then when she can't get out, it's become
the Islamist. It doesn't work anymore.
People have woken up. The generation now
has woken up to your lives of Islamists
and this that it doesn't work anymore.
It's not buying. It's the beginning of
the end of Israel. Mark my words.
I'm not here to defend that. I'm not
here to defend Hamas for I think a
despicable terror organization. But you
said there were 50,000 Hamas. Others
have put the total figure at around
25,000. Which begs the question, if
after 18 19 months now you have been
waging this ferocious war against 25
26,000 terrorists and you still haven't
defeated them. You still can't get your
hostages released. They're still not
being released. It's clear to most
people that your strategy is failing,
but what you're doing is ramping up the
attacks, ramping up the devastation,
ramping up the clearing out of Gaza.
You've got members of the cabinet openly
saying they want to get rid of all the
Palestinians and get them into another
country. So, it seems to everybody else
that what you're actually doing is not
winning any war against Hamas. In fact,
many people think, including
intelligence that the Americans have
received for every Hamas terrorist
you've killed, they've already been
replaced multiple times with people with
the same ideology. And that would
explain why you can't get the hostages
out. And in fact, the hostages, the more
you bombard Gaza, the more you would say
that their own lives become imperiled.
And the overriding picture, which is
what's getting Israel uh so much program
around the world, is that your strategy
isn't working. There's no clear plan for
what happens at the end of all this.
Hamas is still clearly alive and well
and thriving. Yes, you've killed another
one of their leaders today, but you
killed his brother who was the architect
of October the 7th months ago and that
didn't seem to make any difference to
Hamas's ability. And this is one thing
they don't understand the the cause of
the Palestinians be it Hamas whoever it
is it's not just going to die by killing
the figureheads like they they've
targeted the figureheads but the cause
is I don't understand that they to think
that when they've targeted these
figureheads it's over it's not you can
clearly see they've become stronger
they've they've recruited more so it's
not working is losing this war on the
battlefield against Hamas against Hamas
and the resistance they are losing this
battle on the media front they are
losing this battle on all grounds
And Allah, that's what Allah does. Allah
subhana wa tala humiliates you with your
own mouth. That's what like if we could
orchestrate something like this to show
the reality of the Zionist, we could
have if they gave me a trillion pound
budget, I couldn't not have done it.
Israeli is Israeli Zionist. You guys are
doing it for us for free. Thank you.
Recording it for free. Thank you very
much. That's how Allah humiliates you
with your own self without knowing to
continue engaging in battle with you.
And the the the argument remains, how
many Palestinian civilian innocent
lives, women, and in particular
children, are you prepared to kill as
you continue going after Hamas when it
doesn't appear that you're winning that
battle that that strategy is failing? Uh
Pierce, how many Japanese children were
killed under American attacks and how
many battery were killed
by the Second World War. Listen, if you
want to play a fair if you want to play
a fair game, you need to understand how
Western armies operated in the past.
Israel is not anywhere near to the
American attacks on Tokyo that killed
100,000 civilians and not not anywhere
near to what the UK was doing the Second
World War. Now when I'm looking about a
strategy I get nowhere near nowhere near
there's 50,000 innocent people dead
passed away most women and children and
we don't know how many is under the
rubble they're talking about 50 to
100,000 people if you look at numbers
brothers and sisters uh here if you look
look so look at this yeah okay United
Nations noting more than 45 Palestinians
have been killed in Gaza assistant
secretary general tell security council
ceasefire is long overdue yes we have
another BBC nearly 70% of Gaza the war
uh dead verified by UN are women and
children. Yes. So now one thing that I
would say she's making a point this dirt
bag is what that she's talking about
that she's Nazi Germany she's talking
about this etc. Even though Nazi it was
there was a big threat to the whole
entire world. Okay. Um again look
they're using their principles and she's
right. Yes. Pier is like trying to
brush. It's right. She's using because
you know why you guys are cut from the
same cloth. Same thing because this is
your morality. Yeah we can kill
children. No problem. As long as our
objective yeah kill the children. This
is the morality. And guess what? We
Islamist Muslims or whatever. I thought
we are the terrorists. I thought we are
the ones that kill innocent people. In
Islam, it is forbidden. Nowhere in Islam
tells you that you can go and target
children and innocent people as long as
you get the main perpetrator. This is
nonsense. This is why Islam has the
absolute morality, objective morality.
Subhan, nowhere in our text it tells us
to kill innocent people. Hear all the
people criticize Israel today, including
yourself. And then I'm asking you this
question. If Israel finishes the war
today and Hamas stays on our doorstep,
what kind of future do you promise my
children? A future that 7th of October
will happen again and again just like
Hamas leaders promised. This is what you
expect the
Israelis to accept. Hamas shouldn't be
Hamas should not be allowed to run a
welto at the end of all this. They
should have So how do you achieve that?
How do you achieve that? Who's
volunteering there to deitize the Gaza
Strip? With respect, ambassador, you
clearly don't achieve it with the way
that you're trying to achieve it. All
you're achieving at the moment is making
Israel more and more of a global pariah.
When only a few days ago, you have two
doctors in Gaza who have 10 children and
nine of them are killed in a bombardment
by your forces. That doesn't make people
feel, oh, this is all going great. It
makes people think that you're waging a
systematic destruction not just of
property and of land but also of
children. And that's what's happening.
The percentage of children, the
percentage of children that you're
killing compared to the percentage of
you're killing a mass terrorist. What is
it? Do you know? Do you know how many
children you Now, this is where it gets
very interesting, guys. This is where it
gets really interesting because a
question that's asked a valid question
from Pierce Finally. Thank God for that.
Look what she says. Answer me. Ask
Answer me that one question. Do you know
how many Hamas terrorists you've killed
and how many children you've killed? You
know those two numbers? I know the
numbers that came from the IDF. I know
the numbers that came from a very very a
give me the two. Give me the two
numbers. Wait a second. We killed 30
numbers. We killed 30,000 terrorists in
phase one of the war. Since the war is
is back, I don't have the numbers, but
let me tell you one thing. We never How
many children have you killed? They
never target civilians. So this question
is irrelevant. How many children have
you How many children have you killed?
Pierce, Israel is not killing children.
Israel is not killing children. Hamas is
using them is killing children every
single day. This is a blood label you're
putting on Israel. No, it's not true.
Why? No, it's not actually. And what
you're trying to do is be very weasly
with your words. I'm not. The truth is
the truth is you are killing a lot of
children. You would argue you're
hanging lemon.
And you know, let me finish my question
to you. You are killing a lot of
children on a daily basis. That is in
Thank God, Pierce. Oh my gosh. I did not
think the day will come. Weasel Weasley.
No, no, she's weasel. She is a weasel.
Yes. You can see how she's trying to
weas herself out of it. Yes, you are
killing children. You are killing
children. And I'm going to come to how
comes they know the numbers of the
terrorists, but they don't know the
number of children. Let's carry on.
Disputable. My interesting question for
you is how come you know exactly how
many Hamas terrorists you've killed but
you have no idea how many children
you've killed. Pierce, I will give you
the answer because when you are accusing
a country of killing children, it sounds
to all the people that are listening to
us as if Israel wakes up in the morning
and says, "Oo, let's kill is let's kill
innocent people now." This is not what
Israel is doing. Israel, that's exactly
what you're doing. from your lame man in
Israel, Zionist lame man who goes to
work 9 to5 to ministers, cabinet
minister, the interior minister, the
defense minister, Benjamin Netanyahu,
all of you guys from podcast are saying
if we press the button, we'll wipe off
Gaza. You all systematically believe,
all of you, all of you believe that when
ISIS were carrying atrocities, Muslims
free their to do with Islam, stop
religion. You guys do the opposite. You
guys are literally saying ethnic
cleansing. mocking Palestinian men,
women, and children being massacred.
Your influences are mocking them. So
don't come and tell us this is something
you know uh fringe. It's not. It is not.
This is the whole of 95% of Israel
Zionists believe this. You are killing a
lot of children. And my question is how
come you know how many are you familiar
with? Are you familiar with that at all?
Because the international the
international humanitarian law says very
clearly as long as you're targeting
civilian targets you're allowed to
attack host terrorists. No, but you're
not answering my my question. Israel is
now killing children. And this
accusation is a fake thing that you keep
on saying again and again when you know
we're a democratic country cares about
you. I just asked you a simple question.
At the same at the same answer my
question. Hamas is deliberately using
the children as human question and you
know I don't do I don't deny it's
absolutely bull crap there is no
evidence that Hamas is using human
shields the there isn't but there is
evidence about IDF using it you can very
clearly see anything you say about Hamas
that everything you say they are
probably worse I despise Hamas they are
a despicable terrorist organization help
us win this war if you're so despising
Hamas you're offering to surrender
you're not offering to win I'm asking
you I okay I'm asking you this question
for a purpose. I'm curious why you know,
you say you know exactly how many Hamas
terrorists have been killed, but you
have no idea how many children have been
killed. Why is it you know one number
but not the other? I'll give you the
answer because in the end of the day, we
never target civilians. We only target
the terrorist. Why don't you know the
statistics? And we look, you can ask
this question. This is interesting what
you're saying. We don't target
civilians. We target terrorists. They
what what they do the reason why they
think they know this 30,000 number is
absolutely nonsense by the way. Yeah.
Okay. The whole of 30 something say the
whole of 30,000 is Hamas the entire
self. Yeah. And you they've recruited
more. Okay. Is that they are targeting
the way they do it is very
systematically. The wording is very
important. They see a Hamas member and
they're like okay he's there. Okay.
We're going to attack him. Yeah. How
many people around him? Oh uh to 137
people. 137 people are there. Yeah.
Okay. So they say okay yeah attack.
We're targeting Kamas. No, but there's
137 innocent people. None is And
then they write in statistics. We've
killed one Hamas member. They don't
care. They dehumanize. They're like, "We
want to take him out at the cost of 130
Palestinians. No problem." That's why
they know the number, the fake number,
but let's say whatever the number is.
Okay, it's not,000. Whatever it is, they
know those numbers. They don't know the
innocent civilians because they don't
even see them as humans. They're like,
"We killed how many people? Five Hamas
members. How many killed?" "Uh, yeah, we
don't need to know about that." This is
why they know one but they don't know
the other. Are you saying no children
have been killed in Gaza? I didn't say
that. Are you saying that? I didn't say
that. I said Well, what are you saying,
Pierce? What I'm saying is kamas must
have been killed. Kamas needs to be any
child that is being killed in Gaza. Now,
if you want to go into this propaganda
of Israel is doing this and that
propaganda. I'm asking you why you know
how many terrorists you've killed but
you don't know how many children you've
killed in the process. I have an answer
because we targeted those terrorists and
we never targeted any civilians. That's
the answer. And this Did you get it? We
target those look look we target those
Hamas members but we do not target. It's
very simple. Hamas members there attack
this but there it's going to kill 150
people. Let it be. That's why they know
that number. Yes. They say okay we've
got 20 30 etc. at the cost of thousands.
Yep. They say it's worth it. You know
that you know many thousands of ci but
you know many thousands of civilians
have been killed. You understand that?
Do do you understand that you don't care
about my children other Israeli children
by letting 7th of October happen again?
Oh I do. Oh I do. Oh I do. In fact to my
detriment actually in the Middle East
for many many months when I was
defending Israel's right to defend
itself. But now we're at a point where
more and more civilians are getting
killed in collateral damage as you wage
a war and a strategy and a plan which
makes no sense to even your own former
prime ministers who think you're
committing war crimes. So don't just
couch all this as propaganda by people
who just well okay but again I simply
ask you one more time why is it you know
how many Hamas terrorists you've killed
but you don't know how many children
you've killed. Why is that? As I said
again, because in the end of the day,
when you're accusing someone in count
one, you count the other accuse someone
in doing something deliberately while
Israel is doing. Can I accuse the UK of
killing German children during the war?
You would have said it's absurd. Explain
what about explain why you explain why
you know one number but you don't know
the other. And you can see that she's
basically using I don't blame her. She's
saying you've done it. They're both both
buddies. You've done it. We do it. It's
okay. That's the norm now. That's the
norm. We can do it. the question you
want. Why don't you answer my question?
I I'm giving you only the answers that I
have. Just tell me why you know one
number and not the other. But the the
number makes a difference just if you're
targeting civilians. If Israel is not
targeting civilians according to the
international it doesn't make any
difference to the number of children
who've
died any way you difference according to
the
international number of terrorists
killed but you don't know how many
children have been killed. How do you
know one not the other? Exactly. It's
like a mafy boss giving a hit man a hit
a hit on an individual. Go there. But in
the meantime, a couple of people family
members died. No, it's fine. Back to
your question. Did you Did you kill the
main guy? Yeah, that's fine. They don't
care. Let me let me go back to your
question about the journalist. I think
in the end of the day, let them in. We
are coming to the point where
journalists will be allowed to get into
Gaza as long as there is no risk for
them. And you know that it's got nothing
to do with you the risk to journalists.
This is not your problem. From my point
of view, it's not your problem. once.
There is no risk to their life. I'm sure
a load of flannel. Ambassador, don't
treat us like idiots, please. We're not
idiots. You're not doing it for our
safety. You've banned the journalist so
that they don't report on what is
actually happening. Only you know why
you're doing that. I don't know. Maybe
you're doing everything completely
fairly. Maybe it is the most moral war
ever waged in history, as you keep
saying. But the longer it goes on
without you allowing journalists in, the
less people believe that and the more
people believe you have something to
hide. Well, of course, and it's going to
get more horrific for the journalists
when they enter Gaza. You're going to
think, "Oh my gosh, this is just a
glimpse, a tip of the iceberg. It's
going to get more horrific. Hide it from
you." So why do you keep on asking the
same question again and again? I don't
because I don't understand how you can
know how many terrorists you've killed
but you don't know how many civilians
you've killed. Why do you know one but
again I think that it's totally
irrelevant to the main question the
humanitarian how many civilians have
died the international the international
humanitarian law is never about
civilians getting killed. It's only
about who are you targeting. And if
you're
doing warfare, are you happy that people
are going to watch you as an ambassador
to your country say that it's irrelevant
how many children have been killed? It's
not what I said, Pierce. And you're
you're totally distorting my words.
That's exactly what you said. You just
said it's irrelevant. That's what it
shows you that you don't care. You don't
see them as human. You don't care. Now,
here at the end, this is the last clip.
This was so the way they shoot theirel
in the foot. Just watch this. Listen to
this guys. Yeah. your own historian,
Professor Andrew Roberts said when he
sees those circumstances of Gaza, this
is the lowest ratio of terrorists versus
civilians. So this is your own
historian, wellrespected military
historian that is saying that about our
war. Sorry, with respect, how do you
know given Thank you. One legitimate
question for Pan. How do you know that
the ratio to civilian to Hamas members
being killed when you said you don't
even know how many civilians been
killed? Gotcha. You got caught. You got
caught, fool. have no idea how many
children you've killed.
Professor Andrew Roberts did is how do
you know it's how do you know it's the
lowest ratio? You don't know how many
children you've killed. But in the end
of the day, it's not just about children
when you're when you're
comparing like the the the totally wrong
picture. People in the end of the day, I
think people can make their own minds.
At the end of the day, we know who are
civilians. civilians includes also
mature people that are how do you know
the ratio of civilian to Hamas deaths if
you have no idea how many said we gave
you asked me about children I don't have
the answer specific about children but I
do have the answer about civilians
versus but you're aware that you are
aware that it is reported that over
20,000 children have now been killed
you're aware as I said this has not been
backed up with facts and I cannot
approve this number that's it guys what
else can you say peers um don't think
you're getting any credit for this mate
you are going go down history as a pro
genocide of mania. You can do this as
much. I'm just showing the whole world
that even someone like you who had the
threshold has even tipped gone to the
tipping point. But sisters, may Allah
bless and preserve you guys. May Allah
expose them further. It is the beginning
of the end of Israel and may Allah allow
us to live to see the end inshallah and
want and finally the lands are returned
back to the Palestinians where the
Christians, Muslims and Jews live
together inshallah.
Welcome to live with Bet.